[Music]
all right we're back let's go out to
Indianapolis and talk to Lisa what's up
Lisa Hi how are you I'm good how are you
I am good I'm hiding in my laundry room
so we're doing great excellent what's up
so I wrote down my question because I'm
a little nervous very cool read it read
it this is what I have for you um I have
three young kids and I live next door to
someone who went to prison for incest
and sexual misconduct with minor oh oh
good yeah I feel my children are safe as
we have an open dialogue about said
neighbor and they know that anyone from
that house is not safe my issue comes in
interacting with that neighbor um there
have been instances where he said Hi and
um I don't even want to open the door to
conversation with him I also feel my
heart take off anytime I think about who
lives next to me and I don't want to be
affected mentally by this every day in a
negative way
H how old is your neighbor how old is my
neighbor he's um in his 50s okay how'd
you find out about the details of his um
previous um
incarceration
um so my husband's owned this house like
even before I knew him we lived here we
moved we' moved back into this house and
then when we moved back into this house
house I was just I take my kid safety
very um you know serious and I was like
I'm just going to make sure that no one
in town because we live in a really
small town um nobody in town is
dangerous you know and come to find out
he lives right next door so got my
answer um do you know if he's still
under any kind of
supervision uh he's still registered as
a sex offender okay so the first thing I
would do would be to call and see if you
can get the person he has to check in
with and just say I'm a neighbor with
three small kids okay and if depending
on where you live there may be a
violation because he's not supposed to
be in vicinity of said kids this many
yards away okay um probably that's not
the case but it's worth finding out but
by contacting a
supervisor you might
mind that here's the real story okay the
real story
was when he was 26 he whatever or the
real story I know it was like he got out
of prison like within the last 10 years
so right but but it could be that he was
um sexually abusing his daughter yeah it
it could be that he was dating a cousin
right yeah and so
I know it was his daughter okay okay
yeah um and so the second thing is
I I handle these things kind of weird
okay okay I tend to go directly to it
and that's not for
everybody um if the neighbor waves and
says
hello I'm not one to usually just go
kids look at the ground look at the
ground walk
in I like to go across the street and
say hey I'm so and so we're your
neighbors man I got a report that this
happened and I'm super uncomfortable
with my
kids okay and that's just how I handle
stuff um and not in a threatening way in
any shape form or fashion in a
respectful way um and it might be oh no
nothing but I mean it's just kind of
calling it out right the bigger deal is
I don't
want there's a fine line between
vigilance and being smart right teaching
your kids
awareness and making them terrified
about a neighbor right and that's a fine
line I the joke is but it's not a joke
my dad was a homicide detective and he
used to put Polaroids of people getting
out of jail on the family
desk and I was a little kid I mean I was
I don't remember how young I was but it
was like Hey if these guys ever get come
come to the door don't answer it and
that was really
helpful and at a really young age I
internalized hey at any moment a killer
can knock on your door right right and
so I still don't like answering my door
and I'm
old right like I'm an old man now so
there's a fine line between all
neighbors are scary and
terrifying right and so finding that
sweet balance is really smart um and
then the third thing is man just move
why what tell me about this
house um I mean we just moved into it uh
like six months ago and we love it like
we're super happy where we are except
your heart beats out of your chest every
time you walk out the front
door yeah yeah yeah so there's there's a
story that you tell yourself that you
love it but you don't you hate it you're
terrified of it it's like I I'm not
terrified of it I guess like I'm not
scared of him I'm like Angry you know
every go like I don't know I like why
can't everyone just love their kids
right you know and like who does that to
their child yes um keep going keep going
keep
going I don't know I
just it just makes me
angry when think about that and I'm not
hold on anger often covers up grief yeah
how old are your kids uh uh I have a
six-year-old and then I have twins that
are five okay you thought moving into
your home with your three little ones
and your husband was going to look like
X yeah and it was going to feel like X
and instead it feels like why because
you have a child predator that lives
next door to you right it's grief you're
mad right
yeah I just and like I've tried to
to talk to my kids about it in an age
appropriate way because obviously like
I'm not going to tell them like hey this
is who lives NE lives next door and this
is what he did you know I just yeah yeah
and a very like that person is not safe
um if anyone from there ever tries to
talk to you you don't you just come get
mommy um and like that has landed very
well with them they have kids in the
neighborhood that they play with and
their friends went over there one day on
The Neighbors in their yard and my kids
were like they came and got me and
they're like Mom our friends are in
their yard and I was like okay thank you
they're like we did not go in the yard
you know we they they they've listened
they've comprehended what I've said sure
and I've tried not to scare them you
know because I don't want them to be
afraid let's take it one step further
and not related to that house at all but
I think every family needs to have a
safety plan M and talk through good
touch and bad
touch and the the parts covered up buy a
bathing suit mhm and there's a couple of
good books there's a book um it's a
really thin book you can get on Amazon
called good touch and I forgot the name
of the author we'll link to it in the
show notes here um okay but it's a great
little book just to read to kids um that
shows what's good and what's not good
and play through some fun scenarios
about them being at a park or being in a
next door I mean um not not next door
but being at a park or being at a store
or something like that and talking
through no family like only person
you're allowed to have secrets with is
Mom and Dad M any other grown-up you
don't have secrets with okay and and
have your sister when she comes over
like hey can I tell you a secret and
have them say no secrets except for Mom
and Dad right okay and we're GNA teach
him we're going to teach him a safety
plan a foundation underneath this thing
not just that guy's bad right right but
we're teaching them whole body
positivity we're teaching them autonomy
teaching them to pay atten I but we're
doing it in an age appropriate way some
things are private some things only mom
and dad and the doctor can see that's
just the way that goes okay and not in a
you gotta cover that up because we don't
want to teach him body shame either
right right their bodies are amazing
they're perfect just as they were
designed and they're
private both both things are true but I
think having those broader conversations
which are way more uncomfortable if
you're not trained than that guy's bad
don't go in that yard
that's the easy way like talking through
the bathing suit conversation's harder
right the private parts conversation and
if you or your husbands ever had any
trauma around those areas that makes
those conversations even
harder and so but I think that's I think
that's where I would start with my kids
with three little ones um and if you're
comfortable if your husband's
comfortable I think kind of addressing
the issue head-on next time the guy's
out in the yard water in the yard or
whatever um in a non-threatening way
just say hey you got 5 minutes you got 2
minutes just say hey man we just moved
in and we got alerted to this is there
anything you want like anything you want
to tell us cuz I got three little kids
it just makes me nervous right and he
may blow up and then you get all the
answers you need right that's what I'm
afraid of I'm not like a confrontational
person so I mean you just walk away
right I mean if that's if that's the
response my hope would be is that he
would hang his head and say no man I'm I
screwed up 20 years ago I paid my price
never don't you you do not have to worry
about me
um but again I'm naive and super super
super optimistic right um but I think
keeping an eye out is wise but the
bigger picture
is if every time you drive into your
driveway your body tenses
up and every time your kids see you
you're looking out the window they will
absorb their home as a place of
tension and I don't want that for them
and I don't want you to live constantly
Vigilant 247 365 I'm all about being
vigilant all the time but there's
keeping your eyes open head on a swivel
and then there is detecting a threat
detecting a threat all the time all the
time that begins to burn a hole through
you through your marriage and through
your
kids and so I think the conversation is
worth having hey if I'm not better in a
year in 6 months I want us to be honest
about this may not be house for us with
three little ones spending the next 15
years here next to a registered sex
offender but I do want to start here
start with see if you can find find his
sponsor you can track down a sponsor and
get a little bit more informational and
more detail that might put you at peace
or it might say nope we're moving today
we are moving right
now